[Musique]
le dimanche matin à laurine ce qu'on
soit blanc ou noir tout le monde se
consacre à dieu mais pas dans les mêmes
églises
rien dans ce fait qui ne différencie
lawrence d'autres villes du sud des
états unis
sauf qu'ici le racisme a toujours fait
partie du décor était ce qui même dans
le nom de la ville lors il était un
marchand d'esclaves prospère xviiie
siècle pas étonnant donc que le pasteur
kennedy qui a grandi à lawrence soit
devenu un activiste dans le mouvement
des droits civiques des afro-américains
faut un mouvement dont il chante encore
avec quelques uns ses fidèles ligne de
ralliement à l'arrière de l'église ou
ultime soupe populaire
ils ont pendu et ont coupé son pénis
parce que la foule l'accusait d'avoir
dragué une blanche raconte le pasteur
qui n'est dit à propos de son grand
oncle l'une des 185 victimes de
lynchages en caroline du sud
la rue principale de lawrence pas très
loin de l'église du pasteur lui rappelle
d'autres mauvais souvenir pour ça
c'était la porte des [ __ ] explique
kennedy qui a bien connu ces lois qui
imposèrent jusqu'en 1965 une ségrégation
raciale dans tous les lieux et services
publics de la caroline du sud dans
l'autobus à l'école ou cinéma et dans ce
cinéma plein à continuer de fleurir
jusqu'au début des années 2010 dans les
années 90 la vieille salle de lycos
lecture devient propriété du kkk et en
lieu de rencontre du parti nazi
américain
l'écran est remplacée par une croix
gammée et on s'y réunira entre raciste
jusqu'en 2012 pour construire un monde
encore un but à l'avant du vieux cinéma
un certain john world avait ouvert le
redneck shop une boutique de souvenirs
où on vendait toutes sortes de bricoles
à la gloire des suprémacistes blancs
et c'est ici que cette histoire prend
une tournure surprenante
un tel point qu'elle a même inspiré un
film à la fesci ces jours ci aux états
unis intitulée burden michael moore dean
était à l'époque un grand dragon du kkk
locales et l'organisation raciste avait
mis les titres de propriété du cinéma à
son nom pour des raisons fiscales
à la même époque burden vit une période
difficile
il a des problèmes de dépendance manque
d'argent perd son logement il a faim il
pastor kennedy lui vient en aide
ils lui offrent de la nourriture un toit
et même de l'affection pour donna une
révélation tourner le dos au racisme et
quitte le clan du touch mais surtout il
vend discrètement le vieux cinéma au
pasteur kennedy puis au koweït
ce transfert de propriété à occuper les
tribunaux qui ont tranché oui la vente
du cinéma au pasteur kennedy était
valide mais john howard pourrait
continuer à occuper les lieux jusqu'à sa
mort
le red night shop a fermé ses portes en
2012 grandi dans la région lorraine
s'inquiète du nouveau visage de
l'extrême droite américaine
aux etats unis la fréquentation des
sites internet des 10 principaux groupes
racistes a augmenté de 47% depuis 2016
série game freeman qui a convaincu le
pasteur kennedy de faire de la côte est
où un mémorial une maison de la
réconciliation raciale
le jeune homme a même quitté son emploi
pour lever des fonds pour rénover le
cinéma en ruines les u15 2
[Musique]
dans les églises des alentours les
prières pour ramener de lamoura lawrence
sont envoyés vers un ciel ni blanc ni
noir